[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
allez on commence avec les génies du pas
bien entendu vous le savez tous les
jours enfin petit tour de ce qui se
passe dans la télé réalité et on
commence avec mes chouchous les
marseillais on a un peu charrié le
candidat qui s'appelle greg grec c'est
le gars il est sur tous les coups il est
surtout les buy il expliqué hier à une
fille qui s'appelle mélanie oui il était
déjà avec une meuf mais qu' il était en
train de l'oublier
rappelez vous de ça mais c'est entre
charge du contrat à sa autre chose donc
je sais pas si je suis entre elles à
deux passants ont concentré et je reste
sur ma position je m'appelle quand tu es
vraiment passé à l'instinct veut dire
quoi en fait
mais ça veut dire que t'es pas avec moi
si t'as pas oublier notre match à
oublier en fait je comprends c'est pas
gagné
ce sera de l'oublier en fait là l'art
actuellement sans travail et je la dois
continuer alors aujourd'hui il est allé
plus loin parce qu'il explique à me l'a
dit les yeux dans les yeux qu'il va
avoir un qui va voir donc une dernière
discussion avec sa meuf sera la dernière
et après ses terres miner
sauf que greg dès qu'il débarque en
boîte de nuit et ben se passe pas comme
voilà c'est pas voilà moi j'ai besoin de
faire le deuil
j'arrive à passer à autre chose je vais
y arriver je ne sais là ce soir j'en
vois une chine disent que je suis encore
avec elle et après c'est fini je m'en
fous tout le monde dont rds
j'ai tué ma mallette et après c'est fini
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
robin arrêter cette manière alors sebalj
le gars des luttes c'est fini c'est fini
c'est mort quoi ces morts oui et grec ça
fait pas très longtemps qui fait de la
télé réalité je crois que ça fait c'est
la 2eme 3eme faisons pas plus et pas
comme les anciens qui font ça depuis dix
ans et il a été élu meilleur candidat de
télé là où la saison dernière il est
très bon ben voilà c'est exceptionnel le
gars c'est fini c'est terminé je t'aime
pour toi quoi il a dû revoir après
cannes c'est bon d'ailleurs cette maille
veut l'entendre que tu vas sortir et je
suis en train de l'oublier cgt
alors depuis que miley va évoluer dans
les marseillais donc les garçons ne
pense qu'à une seule chose une seule
chose pense qu'à une seule chose c'est
quarto fallait qu'ils veulent pécho
maeva fait mordre la langue
merci alors dans la nature quand de
corte veulent séduire une poule ils
chantent candau lions veulent séduire
une lionne il se bat sur w9
quand deux marseillais veulent séduire
maeva bas ils font ça c'est une
princesse elle est mon frère je pense
que très haut il faudra que tu fous
tonio matin
[Applaudissements]
à
jean de 1800 postes en 1904
[Applaudissements]
suivie à nanterre fasse cette ampoule
c'est fait pour qu'on évite à la rentrée
c'est un immense talent au suivant c'est
fini et franchement y'a bien tu sais pas
d'où on vous régale aujourd'hui à genoux
la vôtre faire la séquence
franchement c'est une régalade c'est une
régalade mais non franchement je les
vois lâché le jeu l'équipe alors les
cherry on va rester dans le thème bien
sûr ce qu'on va passer dont on va faire
un petit tour dans l'émission 4 mariages
pour une lune de miel alors on a trouvé
une candidate qui est fan d'équitation
et qu'à l'oeil bien bien affûté elle a à
mon avis au jeu des sept erreurs elle
allonge où l on trouve huit sauvegarder
et vas-y donc ça a l'air sympa tout ça
non j'aime bien le cadre d'un petit je
fais des courses c'est un fou oui bien
sûr mettre en vente les galets
il se régale au mali
alors là que du très très lourd alors
toujours dans 4 mariages pour une lune
de miel ya une mariée qui a mis le
paquet pour gagner la compétition
elle a carrément voulu engager un
imitateur le seul problème c'est que
nicolas canteloup et laurent gerra il
était pas dispo résultats à la demande
et un certain jean claude j c'est qu'on
kiffe et à mon avis jean claude il a un
peu mitonné sur son métier
ouais il est plus boulanger que
l'imitateur regarder on pense entre nous
que l'imitateur qui sont pris ils
n'étaient pas au top
[Applaudissements]
les cours sont tellement fidèle
l'impression qu'il étouffait il ya deux
voies des voix très émue et très grave
[Musique]
j'ai pas réussi à reconnaître qui que ce
soit dans ses imitations
[Applaudissements]